orcemont commune qui vient tout juste de
dépasser les 1000 habitants réserve une
surprise d'envergure dans son église
saint eutrope se cache un trésor dont
seul le maire peut nous donner l'accès à
bala il est sous alarme et toutes les
barricades et sous alarme le tableau
lui-même et plus alarme le bâtiment à
haute valeur un tableau pas en 1819
commandé par un habitant est offert
depuis à la commune on arrive dans
l'église
et vous avez en face le tableau d'eugène
de la grande île vierge des oiseaux
restait à gauche de l'autel
dans son retable sur mesure la vierge
des moissons du même peintre que la
liberté guidant le peuple livrent tous
ses secrets
on peut manifestement se dire que c'est
quelque chose qu'il a réalisées après la
moisson puisqu'on voit des gerbes au
pied de la vierge et de l'enfant liés à
la pignada plus nyad c'était une manière
à cette époque-là de lier les bottes de
blé dans la sacristie de l'église
on trouve même une boîte digne de
l'oeuvre d'art et ben en fait c'est son
sarcophage qui a été fait sur mesure et
donc le tableau est déposée de son
retard lorsqu'il part à l'étranger
il est installé dans un an ce sarcophage
là et il sert à ça sert bien sûr pour le
transporter là où il sera exposé ce qui
a été fait d'ailleurs récemment en 2004
au japon
je les emmenais la brosse le tableau
voyage et fait voyager le maire de la
commune où tout a commencé
c'est ici à la fermeture à signer que le
jeune peintre encore étudiant aux
beaux-arts reçoit sa toute première
commande
il est arrivé ici jeunes de la croix
pour se reposer étant donné qu'il était
qu'il était souffrant et donc il s'est
installé là aux racines est dans cette
ferme pour sûr pour s'y reposer c'est la
règle donc monsieur bouffier
cultivateurs propriétaires terriens donc
passé cette commande un tableau acheté
15 francs dont le paysage s'inspire
directement des alentours de la ferme
alors naturellement dans la mairie on le
retrouve partout reconnu trésor national
il est parfois amené à s'exposer ça plus
lointaines destinations remonte à 2004
au japon pour une exposition sur victor
hugo et le romantisme
j'étais surpris à chaque fois j'étais
toujours surpris de voir l'importance
qu'ils portaient à ce tableau 1
ne serait-ce que sur les affiches et
puis même même dans la salle
d'exposition où il était exposé on
rentrait sur la gauche il avait sa
petite salle elle lui tout seul dans la
faune et s est vraiment une mise en
valeur mais redore ce monde depuis 18
ans bernard bourgeois s'improvise
conservateur de cette oeuvre d'art et
même guide quand des visites sont
demandés et fierté pour le maire et son
village